you want to keep seducing the person  that you're in a relationship with you  can't do it with the same intensity or  get tiring for both of you because we do  want to settle into a relationship but  upon occasion you have to go back to  those original moments that sparked your  desire for the other person that made  that connection so electrifying and you  need to revive it and you need to do  some of the things that you did before  whatever that is because once the  mystery is gone once people are so  familiar to you there's something that's  lost in there it's not that you're  constantly seducing them it's that you  don't lose the sense of the fact that  you have to think about the other person  and do things that continually surprise  and excite them i don't think there's  anything amoral or wrong about that i  think it's very healthy